BASICS LIKE FOOD COST MORE.
>> Reporter: FOR A COLD, HARD
LESSON ON INFLATION, STEP INTO
THE REFRIGERATOR WHERE CARINA
STORES THE FOOD SUPPLIES SHE
JUST BOUGHT FOR HER POP-UP FOOD
STAND BUSINESS IN PHOENIX,
ARIZONA.
>> SO USUALLY IT WOULD BE THE
BONELESS WOULD BE ABOUT $1 A
POUND.
RIGHT NOW IT'S $1.84 A POUND.
THIS CHEESE USED TO BE $9.
RIGHT NOW IT IS LIKE $14.56.
>> Reporter: TWO YEARS AGO, SHE
OPENED UP TO CATERING SPECIAL
EVENTS.
INFLATION HAS UP-ENDED HER
BUSINESS.
>> HAVE THERE BEEN EVENTS WHERE
YOU LOST MONEY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: AS WE LOOK AT THE
RECEIPTS, SHE EXPLAINS THE
HARDEST IMPACT OF INFLATION ON A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IS HOW
UNPREDICTABLE HER WORLD HAS
BECOME.
THE DEMAND FOR HER BUSINESS IS
THERE.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS A NIGHT
PLAYER.
>> THAT MAKES IT HARD FOR
SOMEONE LIKE YOU TO RUN YOUR
BUSINESS.
>> CORRECT.
IT MAKES IT UNBELIEVABLY
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT ANY
PRICING.
I CAN'T EVEN SAY I'M GOING TO
CHARGE YOU A CERTAIN PRICE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IN THREE DAYS, IT IS
PROBABLY BOUND TO CHANGE.
YOU KNOW?
AND IT IS NEVER FOR THE BETTER.
>> Reporter: PHOENIX, ARIZONA,
HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST INFLATION
RATES IN THE COUNTRY.
THE LATEST STATISTICS SHOW IT IS
THREE PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR
CITIES, AND THAT MAKES LIFE
HARDER FOR PEOPLE LIVING ON
FIXED INCOMES LIKE GERALD
EASTBOUND SPENCER.
>> THIS WAS THE FIRST ONE I EVER
DID.
>> Reporter: AS SHE SHOWS US HER
PAINTING SKILLS, SHE TELLS US
SHE LIVES ON $1,700 A MONTH IN
SOCIAL SECURITY.
SHE SAID SHE PAYS $600 IN RENT
AND AT LEAST $300 A MONTH PAYS
FOR NEEDED KIDNEY AND BLOOD
PRESSURE MEDICATIONS.
THE REST OF HER BILLS LIKE CAR
FUEL AND GROCERIES SHE FINDS
DEPRESSING.
>> Reporter: HOW HARD IS IT
LIVING ON A FIXED INCOME?
>> IT IS HARD.
AND I FEEL SO FOYER FOR MY
FRIENDS THAT DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY THAT I DO.
THEY'RE MUCH WORSE OFF THAN ME.
>> MY COMMUTE IS ABOUT A BLOCK
AND A HALF.
>> Reporter: SO YOU CAN WALK TO
WORK.
>> I WALK TO WORK.
>> Reporter: THAT'S A CHEAP GAS
BILL.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> Reporter: THE WALK HOME FROM
THE CERAMICS SHOP MIGHT SAVE HER
MONEY ON GAS BUST THE NIGHTS
AFTERWARDS ARE GIVING HER DREAD
LOOKING FOR A PLACE TO LIVE.
IN THREE MONTHS THE RENTAL WILL
JUMP FROM $670 A MONTH TO JUST
OVER $1,000.
SHE SAYS HER PAYCHECK WON'T
COVER IT.
>> I WOULD CONSIDER LIVING IN MY
CAR, YES.
I WOULD.
MY SISTER WOULD NEVER ALLOW IT.
>> Reporter: PHOENIX HOME PRICES
HAVE SKYROCKETED IN THE LAST
YEAR.
APARTMENTS SHE CAN AFFORD ARE SO
FAR AWAY THAT PAYING TO GAS UP
HER CAR WOULD THEN BE TOO MUCH.
I WOULD IMAGINE BATTLING THIS,
AT THIS STAGE IN YOUR LIFE --
>> IT'S REALLY HARD.
REALLY HARD.
IT'S --
[ CRYING ]
>> IT MAKES ME FEEL USELESS.
LIKE I'M NOT DOING ENOUGH.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS SHE'S AT
STAGE ONE PANI